[Music]  I've heard tales of your kind which  you're a mutant created by magic roaming  the continent we don't want your kind  here hunting monsters for a price I  thought you'd have fangs or horns or  something  I had them filed down  people call you a monster too  [Music]  [Applause]  why not kill them because that I am what  they say I have all of our choices draw  our destinies closer  he's out there there's still hope  Carol to free me  don't judge me they say witches can't  feel human emotion what do you believe  in even as evil  [Music]  greater  meddling  it's all the same  consistory  your destiny  I can't protect em  if you dismiss it  unleash  upon us all  I'll take that chance  you  [Music]  you